here's the clever and very funny
political junkie you can catch every
weeknight on Late Night with Seth Meyers
one of my favorite shows on TV not just
to be seen um he is you guessed it my
friend as well Seth Meyers are you there
yes and we're matching denim sure it's
called each other I was like you are
your denim yeah
it's Jay Leno gay I know right actually
this does look like I'm working on a car
it's a whole onesie but anyway Wow I
know and I only have literally like four
things I keep switching through cuz I'm
here in Montana have no clothes and I
just keep switching it's just different
shirts that's fine you need to start
keeping a list because I'm definitely
I'm just trying to go two weeks before I
reuse a shirt on television but I'm not
sure yeah I have definitely not
accomplished that I have people are
seeing the same blacktop over and over
again but it's like I'm in Montana it's
no I don't have anything but like warm
clothes here or whatever but um so if
you have you had a conversation in the
past two months that didn't start with
house quarantine going you know I really
haven't I know
I mean it's fascinating dude I mean like
there's never been anything that
everybody's been experiencing at once
like this you know you had friends who
cared about some things and friends who
cared about other things but it really
is you just it would be crazy to start a
conversation without asking I know you
feel rude yeah yeah and and you just
never know what the answer is gonna be
unfortunately cuz my friends and family
that have been affected by kovin so it's
it's big I'm
even on my most depressing days I'm like
okay I'm healthy I'm healthy just keep
saying that I feel the same I I feel the
same way yeah well we may be in a
different time but I wanted to keep our
day-drinking tradition alive so I had
some grain alcohol and I finished it I'm
not gonna lie this was leftover from
Tuesday night the lives in the voice the
lowest yeah
but let's I wanted to mention something
cuz I used a gift of
you because I love you and it's funny so
I I was having the worst day ever
literally my dryer broke my clothes
ended up we have no clothes line so I
just have to hang them on that like the
back porch kind of area and they flew
off into the forest and I had to go find
all of them and anyway it was a really
rough day and then I got back in and my
I had all these texts and they were like
man so now there's murder Hornet so I
was like wait what and I started looking
up like what the hell a murder when it
was and then I anyway use your gift it
was like sure like murder Hornets no I
mean I had on you know I was like this
weekend reading a newspaper article
about it and again it was just one of
those things we did a thing on our show
called not now murder warrants which is
we don't have the bandwidth to be
worried about you at this moment if you
were if you are looking to make a splash
murder Hornet so you picked the wrong
time I think you know you need to do it
before or after a pandemic in the middle
of it I think there are people who are
at this point you know would be
terrified about murder Hornets any other
time better not alike great whatever
bring it on let's just have it all at
once I'm honestly like I and this
happened me the other day to there was
an earthquake here and I didn't know
their worth quakes happened in Montana
and I was just like where are the
locusts coming yeah everything is being
it's just going to crap I don't know
what's happening but it's not i but that
was a bad day but um anyway I just
thought it was funny cuz they like
they're called murder when it's
apparently because they decapitate
honeybees their head off which I was
like of course we would have something
called a murder Hornet right now how is
it like doing your show from an attic
why did you choose your attic I'm
curious we moved around to a lot of
different rooms we were in a neighbor's
garage and that was a little cold and
echoey and then I tried a hallway and
and that was I looked a little bit like
a ghost and then ultimately this this
was both quiet and also the kids
couldn't get up here and then just as it
started the older one got tall enough to
lift the latch and so every now and then
the stairs were sort of right there
every
and then I'll see his little little toe
head papa papa
and just one of these and its really is
the most embarrassing thing about this
is my kids know I I do a show that's
daddy his job is he doesn't show and now
I'm worried that they think that all the
times I've left our apartment in New
York to go to 30 rock they think I'm
also just going into a weird little
attic like I would be like no there's a
big I'm a daddy's a big deal you have a
big deal yeah there's a big there's
lights I know but is it weird your kids
are gonna start doing this because River
and Remmy the younger ones of our fourth
date they start to think that everyone's
mom and dad do the same kind of thing so
they don't understand they don't even
understand it quite yet they're four and
five inna so it's just like they kind of
think like well everybody has a studio
in their house and everybody has a you
know a mom that sits in front of a
camera and talks to you know it's like
it's such a funny thing to watch kids
kind of the funny one thing we'll there
when it's over in them they will be able
to say why are you going to work you did
it at home
I just think here I just think you want
to leave us for eight hours we'll have
to sit them down and say that is that is
why way in order to love you as much as
we need to we have to be away from you
you do need a long time I am with you on
that not aside do you like so do you
like working on homers have been
exhausted it's been exhausting for me
it's exhausting I mean I miss the
camaraderie and I've always valued how
lucky I am to have a job where you
surrounded by people creative people
people who make you laugh so I missed
that a lot you know I also feel lucky
enough that there is a way to do it you
know that we figured out a way to do it
from home but um yeah that part of its
the hardest part is just being not being
around people I agree but watching your
show I've noticed the stack of books
next to you so is that your video you're
just trying to look impressive I'm just
trying to look impressive I've actually
read that and I've actually they made of
like a series on it I've seen it a
series yes this is a very little red
Thorn Birds two more thorns and then
almost never read a Thorn Birds three
things be getting thorny earth-that-was
very clear review before I like I
basically you know I think that you know
people have pointed out you know we're
basically seeing everybody spoke shelf
and that's just way too much I don't
want to reveal that much about myself so
it's mostly every book I've put up has
been like like either books I love or a
joke yeah I'm gonna start doing it and
I'm gonna put like my favorite childhood
ones like my roll down like collections
I don't know I don't want to judge too
hard because I've never written a book
and if I wrote a book I might very well
want behind me but I think it's funny
the amount of people who their book is
her own thing isn't the worse than when
you're I'm so bad at that and in general
in this industry like even for now 20
years I'm so bad at promoting myself I
hate it I feel like such a tool like
even if it's like my song like I'm just
like yeah I mean listen to her down or
like read Matilda's record all like I'm
like I'm like what's the worst salesmen
ever but I do I laugh at that too or
when you go to someone's house and
there's just like a wall of all their
accolades like right when you walk in
there's nothing wrong with it but it's
always like I'm always like I yeah I
think right like I think there's there's
a happy medium between FOIA and attic
and you don't encourage you to read a
little bit farther than you know like
for me I like to by the way I think I
have fewer accolades put it somewhere a
little Easter Egg for people you know no
it's just funny right when you walk in
and like we are proud it's cool um so
are your kids are your boys enjoying
that you are home every day do you get
to do a lot more things than I normally
would with them so yeah I mean it's been
great it genuinely has been great and
out of necessity we have to upload to
the show a lot earlier than when we
shoot in the studio so I have a way more
time with him and the whole first month
I just kept thinking I'm so bad I get to
put my kids to bed at night and now you
know ideally I'll never do it again um
you know I feel like I I feel like I'd
knocked it out
so my said the 40 year old does like an
hour of zoom a day for school because
you know he's just for no today he
yelled because he pressed something on
he was zooming on an iPad me scream that
he had turned it off and then I went
down to fix it and he was just sitting
his pants off and I was like did you
take your pants off after you turned it
off and he goes yeah and I was like
thank God because you might be on a
watch list so let's let's get your pants
back on and turn the most amazing things
we'll just see like reporters like from
their home like the one guy was in his
shorts he had no idea the screen was
that wide that's a meal subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going